foreign
folks welcome to the Dark Horse podcast
I am Dr Brett Weinstein I am of course
sitting with Dr Heather Hein it is live
stream number 140 I don't exactly know
because I've been traveling what number
is it how is that an excuse
uh I don't know it just you know you you
see a lot of new things when you travel
it it fills the mind and I did not uh I
did not have the mental focus to
concentrate on the three-digit number
that would tell us what which normally
you would be spending your days doing
not all of them but you know
meditating on the number it's live
stream number 146. it is and since we
came to you last week eight days ago uh
there's been a guest episode of Dark
Horse which has been released the first
of uh two of similar strain you want to
say a few words about that yeah I sure
do
um it's a really interesting episode and
we will talk a little bit more about it
later in the podcast but in any case it
is a live stream not a live stream Aid
it is a live discussion that I recorded
with military whistleblowers and a
lawyer a former uh officer who is now
representing military whistleblowers and
uh we talk about the effect of
mandates on among other things military
Readiness so in any case I would
encourage
everyone to look at that podcast I think
the reaction to it has been for the most
part quite positive
um and anyway it's it's provocative
stuff you'll find it uh on our YouTube
channel on whatever uh podcast app you
use it's on Spotify the other place all
those places and we do not have a live
stream next week we'll not be coming to
you uh having either pivoted 90 degrees
as we did this week or uh maybe even the
full 360 which you can't tell but we can
claim we did but we won't be doing that
next week uh we will we will not be here
but there will be one maybe two more uh
guest episodes of of Dark Horse coming
to in the interim this week however we
are here it is uh Sunday October 16th is
that right yes and we are going to
follow this live stream as we usually do
with the live q a uh starting with a
question that comes out of our Discord
server every week which they vote on
which is uh they're awesome and then you
can ask questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com whether or not
you're on the Discord server
uh so other other housekeeping things uh
if you're watching on YouTube you can
switch over to Odyssey and join the chat
there where it's live
we have our store
darkhorsestore.org where you can get
Dark Horse merchandise and uh and and
totes and backpacks and shirts and such
with uh with epic tabbies and Pfizer
breakthroughs and YouTube Community
guidelines and and other things I don't
know I was going to say Anvil like but I
don't know that there's a like there
it's it's dark horse inspired
merchandise we came up with all the
ideas on the store and work with an
amazing artist students the renderings
if you want to thumb your nose in power
or you like cats it's the place for you
or direwolves we're direwolves for that
matter okay we are supported by you our
audience we thank you for liking this
video If You Like It sharing it uh and
you can share the entire the entire
episode or on YouTube and odyssey we
have Clips channels as well Dark Horse
Dark Horse podcast clips and those are
often in smaller smaller increments that
are more easily shareable but please
subscribe share like all of that a
reminder that YouTube is not our friend
uh which we wish they were but they're
not they demonetized us and
um and although if you're watching on
YouTube you may see ads that we don't
read on here that doesn't mean anything
about what we are suggesting so for
instance actually uh when we were
monetized by YouTube when we were able
to make any money off of YouTube we
could set the ad schedule such that you
never got our show interrupted in the
middle by YouTube ads we we always
turned that feature off now that YouTube
is running ads on our show and not
paying us any of the revenue they are
generating they put ads throughout this
seems wrong in several several ways so
uh can consider whether or not YouTube
is your friend they're certainly not
ours
you can uh watch us on any of those
podcasts
podcast venues that Brett mentioned you
can also join either of our patreons
which we encourage if you are inclined
to do so you can Brett has a couple of
monthly conversations there we do a
private monthly q a on my patreon and on
either of them you can access our
wonderful Discord
server
where uh wonderful people engage in
honest conversations without fear of
being canceled for having an opinion
that isn't what everyone else already
has and also we have sponsors so every
week we begin our show with reads from
three sponsors whom we have carefully
chosen we do not read ads for products
or services that we don't actually vouch
for so without further Ado here we go
all right our first sponsor this week is
thesis thesis makes no Tropics no
Tropics are nutrients found in nature or
in the human body that enhance mental
performance in areas such as motivation
creativity mood memory focus and
cognitive processing they work best when
combined with taking care of yourself
generally which includes eating real
food moving your body often and getting
good sleep you're probably already using
anotropic as one of the most commonly
consumed nootropics is caffeine but it
is far from the most exciting effective
nootropics allow people to optimize
their focus energy and mood based on the
demands of the day for some people no
Tropics can replace the Pharmaceuticals
that are often used to tackle problems
like ADHD
thesis is unusual in the nootropic
market in taking a very personalized and
scientific approach they do not assume
that what works for your brother will
work for you and that what worked for
you when you were under a deadline for a
dreadful project will be the same thing
that will work for you when you need a
spark of creativity for a project you've
been dreaming of for years just as some
people become alert after a cup of
coffee and others can fall right asleep
so too do all nootropics have different
effects on different people when thesis
first started out they blinded their
customers to what blend they were taking
and took careful data on how everyone
responded to the various Blends not
surprisingly different people responded
differently to the different thesis
Blends now more than 2500 customers and
millions of data points later thesis has
created a recommendation algorithm to
predict which blends of no Tropics will
work best for any given customer
the process is simple go to their
website take a short quiz and they'll
send you a starter kit with four
different blend recommendations to try
over the course of a month
Heather has tried several Blends now and
has liked them all they have she has
returned to several
sorry
my reading skills are not great but this
is actually important right this is the
point uh that uh thesis does not expect
you to to to enjoy all of them or to get
a benefit from all of them it wants you
to try them out and to see which ones
work for you yep have been to like them
all it says here right she has returned
to several repeatedly creativity Blends
smooth things out a bit and adds Clarity
the logic blend facilitates Focus but
your results May Vary with fully
personalizable Blends there is likely to
be a thesis that is right for you get
your own customized thesis starter kit
go uh online and to take thesis.com
Darkhorse take the quiz and use the code
Dark Horse at checkout for 10 off your
first box
wonderful our second sponsor this week
is Mike that's moo plus oink m-lyn K
wink
an eighth generation farmer founded Mike
and is working hard to help save the
family farm and get its customers access
to the highest quality meat on Earth did
you know that 97 of the chickens served
in the U.S are dipped in chlorine well
Family Farms don't tend to do that and
certainly the meat you get from Wake
doesn't
uh the farmers who generate the meat
that you get from White don't do that
because the meat doesn't dip itself the
meat's not going to dip it's I mean it's
not going to dip itself
Mike delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and wild caught Alaskan
salmon direct to your door white Farmers
Farm like our grandparents did and as a
result moink meat tastes like it should
which is to say delicious unlike the
supermarket moink gives you total
control over the quality and source of
your food
you choose the meat delivered in every
box like Ribeyes chicken breasts pork
chops salmon fillets and much more plus
you can cancel anytime we love
everything about Mike the fact that the
meat is grass-fed and finished in small
farms the lovely Publications that come
along with it and of course the meat
itself
Shark Tank host Kevin O'Leary
you know we're on screen right yes I'm
trying to send Zach a text very subtly
okay
oh door
go on okay we love everything about Mike
I don't remember where I was ah the meat
itself Shark Tank host Kevin O'Leary
called Monk's bacon the best bacon he's
ever tasted I agree it's amazing keep
American farming going by signing up at
mikebox.com Dark Horse right now and
listeners of this show will receive free
both filet mignon for a year that's one
year of the best filet mignon you'll
ever taste but for a limited time
spelledmoinkbox.com Darkhorse that's
m-o-i-n-kbox.com Darkhorse
okay our third sponsor our third and
final sponsor this week is mud water
that's m-u-d slash wtr pronounced mud
water it's a coffee alternative made
with four medicinal mushrooms plus herbs
and spices it's got a seventh the
caffeine is a cup of coffee you get
energy without the anxiety Jitters or
crash in the coffee and it's delicious
each ingredient was out with intention
it has cacao and chai Lions made
mushrooms cordyceps chaga and reishi
turmeric and cinnamon among other things
this is a terrific product either on its
own or as a warm drink in the morning
you can drink it black with cream or
honey or both
mud water also makes a non-dairy creamer
out of coconut milk and MCT and also a
sweetener out of coconut palm sugar and
lucuma which is the fruit of an Andean
tree used by the Inca and you can add
either the cream or the non-dairy
creamer or the sweetener if you prefer
those options or mix and match a bit of
their coconut milk and MCT creamer with
some honey from your favorite bees or if
you don't have favorite Bees honey from
your favorite beekeeper and if you don't
have either favorite bees or whatever
beekeeper I really don't know how to
help you who doesn't have favorite bees
yeah I don't I don't know the flavor is
warm and spicy with a hint of chocolate
plus Masala chai which includes Ginger
and cardamom nutmeg and cloves try
blending it into a smoothie with a
banana and Ice milk or milk like
substance
milk-like substance mint and cacao nibs
it's totally delicious and they've also
got a wonderful new caffeine free
product designed to be a drink for
before bed which is also delightful mud
water is 100 USDA organic non-GMO
gluten-free vegan and kosher certified
mud water allows you to build a morning
ritual to promote sustained energy
without the crash visit mudwater.com
Darkhorse to support the show and use
dark horse at checkout for 15 off that's
mud wtr.com Darkhorse use dark horse at
chocolate
check out at checkout use code Dark
Horse at checkout mudwater.com Dark
Horse for 15 off and that is it we're
out all right
um I want to start the hour with a
couple of minor Corrections from last
week yep okay uh we talked about Jon
Stewart in some uh in some depth because
of a recent interview that he did with
the attorney general from the state of
okay
Arkansas I want to say is part of the
Southern a States I think it was
Arkansas apologies if I got that wrong
um and in sort of riffing a little bit
about who Jon Stewart is because we
didn't prepare we didn't do any of our
homework on who Jon Stewart is because
we used to watch The Daily Show back
when he was the host
um I said a couple things that weren't
quite true uh he was not the first host
of The Daily Show but he was the one who
made it huge
uh and he also did not become a farmer
after leaving The Daily Show I actually
gave him a bit more credit than I should
have
um I thought that he had become a farmer
but he and his wife bought a farm but
they didn't use it to grow things they
turned it into a sanctuary for Abused
farm animals which is Honorable
um and now they've got a larger piece of
land which they use as a sanctuary for
animals that were destined for the
slaughterhouse and or live markets so he
doesn't actually grow anything it's not
a farmer but he's a pharmacist
he's a pharmacist he's Farm adjacent his
farmer Jay he's not even far he's like
he's Farm on
um but not actually farming can we agree
that he's far more likable than a lot of
people
you know I think so but I gotta say that
interview did not did not uh inspire me
any well we'll see maybe maybe he'll
level up I mean I think you know in in
large measure what we said was critical
of you know how deeply he dug before he
uh ventured an opinion that is at odds
with reality and you know I would like
to believe that he is an honorable guy I
really think that's true and that upon
discovering his error he will level up
that's my hope I hope so too I guess
um you know we've been some people
appreciate a lot a lot of people
appreciate what we're doing what we are
doing and we appreciate hearing from you
uh and some people a few people who are
long time fans have said
could you ease up on the vaccines in the
trans already like it's always vaccines
or trans that you're talking about and
the coveted vaccines
and uh when I see that critique I think
but these are the two places that feel
like we are seeing most clearly the
failures of the most number of our
systems and we are at a a Tipping Point
so many people are being damaged and uh
and you know there's it's it's not I'm
I'm not obsessed but I can't avoid it
like everywhere you turn you run into
these to these stories with people
getting it way way wrong and doing
damage to people often who are innocent
right
and I feel like you know Jon Stewart
going on air and citing uh
institutions that are getting it wrong
in many places as the evidence that it's
okay to hormonally transition your
prepubescent or you know stop the
development of your prepubescent child
I'm sorry but you know have you met
humans like do you really have that
little understanding of of what humans
are and so I guess I have in some ways
um less patience for the people who are
going along with the Trans thing than
for the people who have been hoodwinked
by the coveted vaccine authoritarianism
and and and media play that has been so
Universal uh it's it just it feels like
actually
because you have been living on this
planet you have enough information to
know that this is not okay well I agree
with that I also think
um you know yes we did not choose these
topics we would not uh stick with these
topics so long were we free to be
talking about what we think is most
interesting the problem is
some stories diagnose the system and
what we are dealing with is a
catastrophic failure of our system based
on the collapse of every institution on
which it depends and really
I know that sounds like an exaggeration
but it really is every institution and
if you think it's not I challenge you to
find the institution that is even
treading water while speaking the truth
and uh looking out for for common people
so to the extent that you may find us
too long on topics that are really no
fun uh the reason is because until a
these are among the very best ways to
see the failure of the system and the
failure of the system really is the meta
topic and until these things correct we
know that we are nowhere right these are
the glaring instances that most people
can see you know enough to know that for
example there are two Sexes and that
when your major scientific journals
start speaking as if that's not true
based on some finding that they imply
has been uh attained by science
generally a they're lying B you can see
it C your intuition is enough to tell
you something is way the hell off and
then it leads you to D which is okay
we need an extraordinary explanation
to get to why your major scientific
journals would be saying anti-scientific
things
so we're at least in that quadrant and
um that really is the larger point to us
focusing on these things and revealing
all of these examples the fact that the
examples keep emerging that we are not
having to delve into history to find new
egregious examples tells us that
whatever is wrong with our system is
still very wrong and it still owns these
properties that frankly
um the public must recapture exactly
one more correction from last week sure
inquiring minds want to know
you asked I don't remember exactly you
were making some pun
uh about euas maybe uh in which you
spelled inquiry with an e and I said
rather dismissively honey this is not
how it's spelled well I looked into it
yep and it turns out that inquiry and
inquiry are both no longer really used
but both historical uh uses of or or
spellings for the term that inquire with
an e is more common in British American
British English than in American English
and but but disappearing as well
traditionally in England inquire with an
I was reserved for more formal occasions
and end choir just with an E just meant
to ask
um and you know inquiry versus to
inquire
I don't know which one you're saying
where an inquiry is a formal which one
which spelling is that oh I have no idea
so what what are you making I can hear
it yeah an inquiry presumably with an
eye is like an inquest right it's a
formal process it may well be the same
really look into that actually our OED
are is still boxed because almost all of
our books are still in boxes we're still
waiting on our bookcases well I also
would say that having our OED in a box
prevents anybody from messing with it
which I'm pretty sure is going to happen
sooner or later so that we can no longer
even look up what words used to mean
when we bought these books we've we've
got a hard copy of the Oxford English
Dictionary for which I am grateful uh
but
um yeah actually I went to look at the
OED online and they wanted a lot of
money and you know I may end up doing it
but I thought no you know we got it in a
box somewhere I just need to buy it
comes with a magnifying glasses its own
drawer for its own magnifier absolutely
it's yeah kind of a flimsy drawer but
yeah but um I did I wanted to to point
this out because you weren't going to
discover this no no and I believe that
this marks a win for you for Brett in
the spelling category which I admit I
never expected to see happen well this
is two wins really in the spelling
category yes because I believe in he's
greedy is he not I mean look I'm just
I'm
I'm into this
well look first of all you've got it
you've got to give me a little leeway
here because having won a spelling Point
yeah I really strategically have no
choice but to quit at this moment
because instead instead you're you're
just trying to like no I'm celebrating
as I'm seeing my exit at the end of this
episode I have no obligation to tell you
you did not have any look
the the two wins are that I happen to
have sort of been in the right
neighborhood with respect to inquiry and
inquiry
um
well by misspelling some things last
week I came close to solving the problem
of you know fact checking right so using
spelling as a solution is not something
you would expect me to do because I'm
not good at it and anyway I thought that
was kind of a win and then here too this
uh okay so this is this is the Pinnacle
of my spelling career certainly yeah or
last week was last week yeah and uh
anyway so which I mentioned just to
point out that you're already on the
downslope
it does feel that way
yeah yeah well anyway yeah well
congratulations thank you yeah I
appreciate that yeah and that was very
kind of you to dredge that back up and
uh and reveal it here in front of our
entire audience yeah indeed all right uh
so we have a few places we want to go
this week uh I don't know if you want to
start you want me to start
why don't you start why don't I start
okay uh I guess before before we really
launch into the content I will say I
mentioned that we
turned the set 90 degrees we're still
not in our in our final place where we
will have
in the shade yeah the camera is actually
slightly slightly tilted you can see the
wall to Brett's right is the wall that
we have usually been sitting in front of
and that's a real that's a it's not a
virtual wall that's that's the real deal
people are so unhelpful
I
let's all right this must be
scintillating for those listening to the
audio versions of the podcast where was
I even going with that
um thanks Zach sorry why
um
should we start over I really there was
I don't remember I was mentioning that
for a reason and I don't I don't
remember that we are not in our final
yeah it doesn't matter I don't know I
had I had some cool segue but um
I guess oh I know I don't I forgotten
the call Segway but the piece of
information I wanted to convey was uh
that here with our clerg uh setup that
we have to set up that these two guys
have to set up and break down every week
uh we don't have an ability to screen
share with my computer so uh I I don't
have
I don't have the things that I would
love to share in order to really reveal
this next little story but
we talk a lot about science and the need
for science as a tool for Humanity for
functioning democracy for systems that
actually allow us all to live our best
lives and prosper without getting in
other people's ways and we have in the
past talked some about art as well but
not as much although long time listeners
and viewers will recognize that I in
particular but also Brett are um are
very much Advocates of art as a as a
necessary and our screen just went to
distance that's not showing the audience
okay
um
that art and the Arts uh are absolutely
necessary and critical components of the
of the human experience as well and
um and that art and science uh
interestingly when when we were College
professors for those for those many
years for those 15 years a period of Our
Lives which seems upper more distant
somehow uh I often found that the
approaches that the curricular
tools the pedagogical tools and that the
kinds of ways of learning and
approaching the world that artists and
scientists took and that art students
and the self-identified art students and
science students had were much more
similar in to each other in many ways
than those being employed by the social
scientists and the humanities types
which was a little surprising and I
think in part it's because there is
actually a tremendous amount of
creativity in science that those who
don't do science think of it as being
all about the rigor and the metrics and
the reductionism and again those of you
who are familiar with us will know that
we we very much value rigor and metrics
and reductionism have come to replace
much of what is actually science and our
stand-in for that and of course that's
part of how we get to proclamations like
follow the science which tells you right
away that the person saying that has no
idea what science is so the the openness
to Observation to new patterns that you
may not have seen before or been able to
explain before is uh is part of what
brings both Art and Science together can
I add a dimension to that
um so I also find very interesting the
um the the Confluence between these two
things and it seems to me that you've
just pointed to one you know that the
artistic exploration reveals these
things but there's also a way in which
in many kinds of art maybe all of them
the solving of technical problems allows
the artist to say some things that
couldn't otherwise be said and I'm
thinking at the moment especially about
sculptors
and the fact that a sculptor can take a
piece of stone and a really skilled
sculptor can make it appear to be a you
know a very sheer piece of cloth right
that is an amazing Gap to jump to take
something as hard as marble and to make
it look soft and and cloth like or to
make it look like skin in a compelling
way
um and so anyway the point is what you
and I say about the importance of
interacting with physical systems in
your education systems in which there's
no social uh evaluator of whether you
succeeded or failed now you could say
that the viewers of the art are the
evaluators of whether you've succeeded
or failed but nonetheless the point is
if you didn't get close then it isn't
even really going to reach an audience
worth reaching and this is so this
becomes less true the more abstract you
are yep
um but but this is very much true for
craft craft effectively being functional
art so you know does does whether or not
it's beautiful is to some degree in the
eye of the beholder but whether or not
it's functional is is not a a social
decision right you know does is the
table level does the vessel hold water
uh you know does does the blanket retain
warmth and not Ravel at the edges uh and
you know I'm reminded too this is
something I've said on here before
of my Discovery late in our graduate
careers of pottery where I was at the I
was at that stage in the scientific
process so at least the stage in
graduate school that is the the most
tedious for many people it's I because
we were both doing field field work uh
all of the create all the creativity was
already passed I had done the
observations I had made the hypotheses I
had collected the data in the field I
was now back uh in Michigan having to do
the analystical analysis which had its
moments uh and the literature review
which had its moments but then the
write-up which leaves sort of no room
for creativity it's not the kind of
writing that has any Intrigue at all so
I actually I wrote a different book at
the same time as I was doing that to
help me you know find my creative outlet
that way but I also started doing
Pottery at a local artist Cooperative in
Ann Arbor and I found it so appealing in
part because it brought together and I
mostly did wheel throwing and so I was
mostly making functional pieces but it
brought together uh an ability to learn
a bunch of technical stuff about glaze
chemistry about oxidation versus
reduction
firings about different cones about
different clay bodies about the forces
that your hands and the wheel put on the
clay in different speeds at different
directions all of these things but also
so when you hold a piece of pottery in
your hand does it feel like it's the
right weight
and if you haven't ever considered that
maybe you think well I wouldn't know but
trust me you would you know maybe not
the degree that I would you know you
probably don't automatically turn a
piece over to see how it's been trimmed
when you find a new piece of pottery but
many pieces especially made by Potters
early in their work including you know
we still have a couple of bees of mine
like they're just too heavy yeah it's
more clay than you need to do that it's
more clay than you do the job and the
walls are if on a bowl the walls are
thicker at the bottom rather than having
been
um rather rather than having been
um not just imagined but actually
executed with something akin to
Perfection right now the Potter could
choose once they've learned to do the
thin walled thing they could choose to
do something that you know but it
doesn't it doesn't have to be thin but
uh even even depth is actually you know
and you know thin for porcelain so you
get some Sheen through it maybe and
thick through for stoneware or um or or
red clay so I wanted to I wanted to
point out
um
making a bicycle frame is not exactly
art right there is there's an art to it
and in fact
um
story for another time there are these
uh these bike builders storied bike
builders French bike builders called the
construct tours who
um knew things about how to build a
bicycle that we still have not been able
to unpack we don't know why their
bicycles work better because it was not
explicit what they were doing it was
something so there isn't there's
definitely an art to it but what I
wanted to point to is just at the
technical level and I've I've built
exactly one bike frame
but it's but it's both gorgeous and it
is the bike that you ride I ride it all
the time I you know I would love a
chance to do it again there are some
things about it I would change but no
it's it's pretty darn good but it took
me way longer than uh an expert would
have taken there's some mistakes in it
that I know are there but but the thing
I wanted to point to I built it with a
technique called Philip brazing and
Philip brazing involves liquefying brass
and using it essentially like a solder
to join tubes together and if you see a
bike that's had this done to it unless
somebody's gone out of their way to use
only a transparent coating on it it
looks like the tubes just seamlessly
blend into each other it's a smooth
transition from one tube to the next as
opposed to the is it the brazing that
leaves the as opposed to welding Welding
which leaves a line of liquefied you
know if you take two steel tubes and you
weld them together you've got the place
where the steel was liquefied at the
joint and you can see it which can also
be done very well but it's not near
nearly as subtle so the thing about the
fillet braising so that the liquid brass
is the fillet right what is fillet I
don't know this word outside of this
context
I don't really know it's it's the
uh an engineering term for a chamfers if
you have two edges that are like this
and you cut them so it's you know 45
degrees at each so Zach's I don't know
how well people can hear Zach but you
said it's a it's a champ for yeah a
chamfer is when you have two edges that
meet and you cut them so maybe it's not
45-45 but it's two angles nice and flat
yep is when it's rounded and you can do
that with different algorithms but okay
so so Zach is saying affiliate is a
rounded joint which makes perfect sense
with with what I'm describing but the
point is
there are ways to do affiliate badly in
which there will be voids inside of it
that's not a strong joint and it will
fail
um the correct fillet is full of brass
all the way through doesn't have Bubbles
doesn't have cracks anything like that
oh just like with just like with Clay
just like with canning just like with
anything you don't want air pockets but
here's the here's the connection to to
your point about pottery
an amateur can do a perfectly good
fillet but what they do is they use too
much brass and then the thing that makes
the fillet smooth is all of the work
afterwards where you come back and you
eliminate all of the brass you didn't
need and it takes forever if you have
done an amateur joint The Joint will be
just as good when you're done but you
might spend 10 times as long getting to
done clean up yeah on the cleanup phase
which was very very interesting to
discover I certainly my my fillets were
good but wow did I was there too much
brass yeah and do you want to uh give a
shout out to of course of course yeah I
did this at the United Bicycle Institute
in Ashland Oregon they have a two-week
course they will teach you to do this
you don't have to fill a brace you can
use lugs you can do Philip brazing at
the end of it you have built a custom
bike frame you choose everything about
it you design it you build it and I
haven't looked into it recently but it's
pretty close to cost neutral right what
you would pay for a custom bike is more
or less what it costs to build one so
well if you don't include your time so I
think it's a two-week course and then I
think you also did the three day like
TIG welding at the end
um so that's that's a lot of time for a
lot of yes right but you know if you're
if you're in a position where you can
afford that time and are thinking of
buying a custom bike frame maybe make
your own yep but then you do also have
to um
you know you gotta eat it perfect and
then you also have to have it painted
which isn't free yep uh yeah but anyway
it's it's a great experience I and you
know maybe half the people in my course
actually went on to uh build bikes
professionally so it's a course for
people who are serious about it anyway
it's a really cool thing to do and uh
living in Ashland Oregon for a couple
weeks is cool too yeah
okay so we're talking about art
um
because I see Art and Science and we
both do as bulwarks against stupid
and you know all all human inquiry
ought do that to some degree but
um Art and Science particular protect
against stupid and help us find truth
and beauty and our shared humanity and
both are
failing and I I was collecting for a
while and have not collected all of the
pieces that I wanted for here today but
I just I'm
this week
a contact of ours in the American
entertainment industry sent me a few
things that I wanted to share
um
not
uh not as indicative of the entire
system but clearly indicative of
something that is going on specifically
in
the movie industry
um specifically we've got some standard
requirements from auditions which again
I would share my screen here if I could
but I can't so I just have to pull it up
apologies I wasn't totally
um prepared for this so some standard
uh this is again standard requirements
from auditions in the entertainment
industry and the American entertainment
industry we have the first one with
regard to covid-19 Talent must be
vaccinated booster's optional
parentheses not required
okay
uh second one October 19. again
requirements for auditions in the
entertainment industry vaccination and
booster if eligible are required kids
that are not eligible for a booster just
need to be vaccinated
and the third one oh and this is
um
a little small for me to see uh and I'm
gonna so this mentions Zone a and I
asked this contact virus uh what zone a
means so before I read what the standard
requirement from this Edition that zone
a refers to those working at the center
of the job so X is going to be the
talent the director uh the Director of
Photography the script supervisor the
assistant directors hair and makeup just
like the crowd gathered around those in
the center of the scene being shot those
who are hands on with the talent
um so that's what zone a means so FYI
this again from the entertainment
industry
production will require mandatory
vaccination for those working in zone a
which includes the ages 5 to 11. as of
February 18 2022 if you are offered a
role you would be required to verify
that you're up to date on your covid-19
vaccination and your employment in zone
a would be conditioned on that
validation up to date means the
following
a two-dose Pfizer covid-19 vaccination
series and if eligible a booster dose
for those who are five plus months past
their second shot currently this Pfizer
booster is approved for everyone ages 12
and up
or a two dose modern covid-19
vaccination series and if eligible a
booster dose for those who are five plus
months past their second shot currently
the moderna booster is approved approved
for everyone ages 18 and up or a
single-dose Johnson and Johnson covid-19
vaccination and if eligible a booster
dose for those who are two plus months
past their single dose currently the
Johnson Johnson booster is approved for
everyone ages 18 and up but an mRNA
booster is recommended in many cases
fourth bullet point if you are not
eligible if you are not yet eligible for
your rooster shot your vaccine status is
considered up to date you must obtain
your booster promptly once you become
eligible and submit validation that you
received your booster
so this in the week that what was
already well findable in the early
documents has become mainstream news
which is that Pfizer didn't actually
test in the clinical trials for whether
or not their shot blocks transmission
and of course there's all sorts of
gaslighting and reconfiguring of what
was actually said going on now about
like well they never claimed they did
and this that and the other it's like
what possible explanation explains
mandates here in the military in the
government for Ferry workers for medical
workers anywhere if the thing isn't
blocking transmission how do you make an
argument for mandates if it's not
blocking transmission and how therefore
are people arguing that they never
claimed that it did but maybe most of
the point how is it that our military
that our entertainment industry that
other places are still requiring this
insanity
how is that happening I agree Arts have
fallen science has fallen Arts have
fallen it's such a simple set of points
if it doesn't block transmission then on
what is the Mandate based and why would
you not value the risk even if we didn't
know that there were harms and we
absolutely do know that there are now
Harms
but even if you didn't know by value the
rescue me and assess the value of the
rest I mean incorporated into the
calculations certainly the idea that
these mandates are being pointed at
young people children five and up five
and up if you want a job in the
entertainment industry if you're that
kid if you've got that kind of talent
and drive and it's not just your parents
or something
you have to take on this crazy cost
it's so it is
how does one even describe it you are
being forced to demonstrate your failty
to a
anti-scientific mandate that actually
puts your life in jeopardy in an age
stratified way not only is the risk of
covet age stratified so that young
people really don't need these things
again it's not blocking transmission so
vaccinating young people it would be
immoral to vaccinate them to protect old
uh enfeebled people but it's especially
insane given that this does not prevent
them from transmitting the Disease by
getting it or transmitting it to people
who are at risk so the the the Steel Man
response there will be uh but uh the
vaccinator putting all of the the
unvaccinated put in all of the stress on
the system by showing up in hospitals
and droves and therefore it's your
obligation to the system to um
well there are 16 different I don't want
to make fire come out your ears
responses to this but it's a look if the
problem was that we were in an emergency
where we really had a you know
insufficient resources to deal with all
of the people who are being sent to the
hospital over covid then a and there was
a and there was a shot that actually
reduced the chances of you ending up in
the hospital right you still would not
be acceptable to vaccinate kids
especially given that they have an extra
risk from the shots and especially given
that they have low risk from covenant as
a matter of fact exceedingly low risk if
they have no comorbidities but you
wouldn't be firing doctors and nurses
right you wouldn't be crippling the
system by reducing the number of
resources we have to throw at the people
who have ostensibly been sent to the
hospital and
you wouldn't be simply punishing the
unvaccinated which of course again makes
no sense here but you would be saying
this is a moment in which we cannot
afford any high risk behavior right if
falling off your motorcycle can send you
to the hospital and you're going to take
up a bed and somebody's not going to
have a bed and they're going to die
because of it this is not a moment for
motorcycles right or only to and from
work or whatever right we are not across
the board telling people do not engage
in high risk behavior because covet is
filling our hospitals because it's not
nor
are we telling people this is the point
we've been making from the very
beginning nor are we telling people to
take the parts of your life under
control that you can take under control
and deal with the comorbidities that you
may have that you actually have agency
about okay yep once once you are an
adult if you have metabolic syndrome and
are pre-diabetic or fully diabetic and
have the beginnings of kidney disease
and are morbidly obese there was a very
good chance that it's going to be
extraordinarily difficult to get
yourself back to a baseline that is
considered very healthy but you can move
the needle in the right direction and it
is those comorbidities that are creating
the most number of problems certainly
for the young but even for the middle
aged and and early Elderly with regard
to coping and there are things that
frankly take no significant effort on
your part at all that make a huge
difference like vitamin D which we're
not recommending right so the whole
system is clearly hell-bent on getting
you not only to accept anti-scientific
beliefs but to put your own health at
risk over them even though it doesn't
give a [ __ ] about your health from the
point of view of telling you yeah you
should take some vitamin D because it it
is likely to help you fend off this
disease far more effectively it's not
interested in your health in a positive
sense it is interested in you not
resisting nonsense at a medical level
and that raises all kinds of questions
it does it really does
um Okay so
science
gone off the rails the Arts gone off the
rails
Wikipedia
gone off the rails uh we're not going to
spend a ton of time here we've talked
before about
um the loss of what was a relatively new
and extraordinary resource for all of
humanity to the woke crowd but there's a
and I'll link this in the show notes
there's a Twitter thread of all things
um but that but that shows the
references that has the receipts on some
of where the money that you might be
giving to Wikipedia is going so everyone
who uses Wikipedia gets those uh gets
those requests at the top every now and
again or sometimes you know some months
it's all the time that says you know we
are reader supported I don't remember
exactly what it says but uh you know we
we rely on you to support us and you
know it's very expensive to do what we
do yada yada yada well
um we find in this thread and again I'll
link to it and I can't show you right
now
um but in the in a decade what Comedia
spending has gone from 10 million
dollars in 2010 to 112 Million by 2020.
that's an order of magnitude and that's
a lot uh and yet
um it's basically the same website right
so what happened uh maybe it's that more
people are using the site the uh this is
ashitis
um person who is making this thread
um
says maybe it's more expensive to run
well nope website hosting costs only 2.4
million in 2021 Which is less than it
did in 2012. so that's not it
um but what we find so Wikimedia
Foundation is the is basically the
overarching uh
I don't wanna I don't know exactly what
it's called but you know it's parent
organization it's the entity yeah it's
the entity that funds Wikipedia
um they their own website shows that
less than half of what they spend goes
to directly supporting the website and
they break it down as follows 42 direct
support to websites
14 Administration governance 13
fundraising 31 direct support to
communities
what's that what's direct support to
communities certainly sounds good sounds
good I like I like supporting
communities the sports positive and
direct well you cut out the middle band
you wouldn't want the middleman we're
going to be the media Foundation is
probably a middleman but okay never mind
we don't want to pay attention to that
um but no the middleman here is directly
supporting the people that you would
definitely want to support because what
we do know for sure is that Wikipedia
Wikimedia Wikipedia is neutral they are
philosophically neutral politically
neutral of course they tell us that
right aren't they well I will tell you
that
um I gave as you know I gave a a talk uh
at Arizona State University
um at the launching of their new uh
Center for American institutions yeah
say something about this this is where
you were keynoting and um
I think it's a reminiscent yeah yeah
okay
um but what were you talking about ASU
uh Wikipedia uh back further the uh
direct support to communities direct
support to communities damn it I've lost
them I'll have it back in a second I did
that to you okay you did um
I definitely want to hear about uh I
want them to hear about your talk at the
keynoting
okay at ASU well oh I know what it is
um in preparing for my talk I was
talking about because this is the center
for American institutions
um I was talking about the
across-the-board failure of our
institutions and one of the institutions
that I used as an example was Wikipedia
and in looking at that example I did
something that I just don't do anymore
ever which is looked at my own Wikipedia
page and found
it's gotten even worse and more
Preposterous and more completely at odds
with easily ascertained facts than it
was before it just it's not just super
slanted it's actually factually wrong
factually incorrect right it's not that
it misinterprets the fact it reports
things that didn't happen right and you
know of course there's no real recourse
but
um anyway so yes it's uh it's uh um
uh uh looking for a nice synonym for
[ __ ] but I can't find one no no
it's hard it's hard so I did when
thinking about this I didn't actually
know that you talked about that two days
ago
um but I went and I was like okay I'll
check I'll see what my Wikipedia entry
looks like and uh yeah it's crap it is
bad it is they are so bad and um and you
just you just gotta wonder and yet but
if you want to know what album human is
you can look it up on Wikipedia so you
know yeah that sort of thing and uh
presumably uh that not being a
politically charge large topic as
apparently we are you can get you get
accurate information sure
so Wikipedia emphasizes a neutral point
of view but Wikimedia is openly
politicized as this thread points out uh
and they so for instance here we go uh
what we mean by racial Equity this is uh
appears to be this is a screenshot but
this appears to be a screenshot of the
Wikipedia Foundation
um actual Wikipedia entry the Wikimedia
Foundation defines racial Equity as
shifting away from eurocentricity white
male imperialist patriarchal Supremacy
superiority power and privilege to
create an environment that is inclusive
and reflects the experiences of
communities of color worldwide these
modes of privilege mentioned above
function of setting the dominant social
political legal policy oriented and
cultural norms around the world
okay so they're you know what what did
they claim to be
um oh wait hold on they claim to be
lost it uh taking a neutral point of
view it doesn't sound neutral to me I
mean
do they even hear themselves no they're
trying they're trying to define a term
like Equity a term that I will point out
used to have you know a meaning right
they can't even Define it without
reference to specific groups
right they have to Define good people
and bad people in order to define equity
this is insane yes they do
uh so just one I'll just take one more
example here from this thread and again
I'll link to it uh the person writing
the thread said okay well let's see what
some of this direct Community Support
looks like and it many millions many
many millions tens of millions go to you
know in the form of grants that the
Wikimedia Foundation makes from the
money that you donate to Wikipedia and
turns it into grants that it's calling
direct Community Support well the search
Foundation received uh quarter million
dollars donor cash uh the search
Foundation stands for uh stem on route
to change
the grant was given to provide quote a
two-year investment to the search
Foundation to support the expansion of
their signature program Vanguard stem
which amplifies the voices of black
indigenous women of color and non-binary
people of color in stem Fields the
search foundation will leverage cultural
production including multimedia
storytelling to advance non-traditional
forms of knowledge creation to build
freely licensed and open rich media
content about stem leaders of color and
address inequitable representation
throughout scientific Fields okay
fabulous uh however on closer inspection
it turns out to be even more unusual
they are proponents of
the intersectional scientific method
the intersection I think we took science
too early to have learned the
intersectional method is it is it very
good I've got an abstract from them all
right in describing how Vanguard stem
descended from counter spaces we draw on
speculative fiction to define a Vanguard
stem hyperspace as a fluid police time
that is born digital and enabled by
social media but materializes in the
physical world for specific purposes as
black women in stem we consider how our
situated knowledges and scientific
expertise inform our process
there's been one new video on their site
in the last year
they discuss issues in science like
objectivity which they're against
there's just a couple of screenshots
from this video with some text from it
so we always want to talk about an
unbiased approach
but is that really what we want they ask
objectivity they say is sort of a
conquering gaze from nowhere that's a
direct quote but that sounds real
colonialist to me
this is the supposed
stem initiative that got a quarter
million dollars from the Wikimedia
foundation and it's hardly the only one
so do you understand this to be where a
large fraction of them when they beg you
on Wikipedia and they say please donate
so that we can keep doing our important
work and you think they're saying that
this is necessary to keep Wikipedia
functional that they're in fact
delivering it to these political causes
is that what's going on like like I said
and you know I have I have not gone
deeper than what I find in you know
clicking through some of the links and
such in this thread
um but what the Wikimedia foundation's
website itself suggests is that of the
money that they receive they have 42
percent uh going to direct support to
the websites websites they say which I
guess means Wikipedia and the Wikimedia
Foundation websites I'm not sure exactly
if there's additional sites 14 to
Administration and governance 13 to
fundraising and and 31 percent direct
support to communities
and included in that direct support to
communities and maybe making up the vast
majority of that direct support to
communities is the grants that are going
to organizations like this
whatever the hell that was called
so they are pretending to be objective
as they are misreporting the facts on
Wikipedia and politicizing the world
out the back door yep
unbelievable unbelievable yep so that's
science art uh once Public Access
publicly written encyclopedia which that
was new like we've had science and art
for ages we did not have a publicly
available
widely like just just incredible
encyclopedia for the masses until I
don't know
10 years ago 15 years ago right
Wikipedia is is since the turn of the
last Millennium for sure and
it's dead now
yeah I mean it still exists for things
that really can't possibly have any
political component but you cannot use
it in the way that you could use it
before and you certainly can't donate to
it and hope and hope that it will go to
help you know unpoliticize anything
because it's actually behind the scenes
making the culture wars worse
what you can't do is trust it right at
best what you can do is trust your own
assessment of what topic might be so far
from anything in which there is a
cultural Battleground that it might
actually report the facts uninflected
right but how good are you at knowing
where the bodies are buried right yeah
if you're going there presumably you're
at least somewhat ignorant of the thing
for which you're going right so the idea
I mean and you know as I pointed out at
ASU the worst part about having uh
Wikipedia and Wikimedia so thoroughly
politicized is that they take up all the
oxygen in the room that we desperately
need an encyclopedia available to
everyone that is dedicated to reporting
the facts of every discipline as best as
we understand them and this prevents us
from generating it because we have
something that looks like that and used
to Aspire to be that and is now just
taken over by Insanity yeah no and you
know to hearken back to last week's show
exactly as fact-checking festivals
are springing up
by these new fact-checking organizations
which itself wasn't a thing right until
fairly recently exactly at that moment
we have the denigration and effective
disappearance of of Wikipedia such that
the ability of the average person to
actually assess what is and is not true
has become much more difficult if not
impossible in some regards yeah it's uh
couldn't be a bigger bigger tragedy and
really goes to the larger point that
you need a special explanation for the
failure of every institution
simultaneously right that that's not the
result of just
you know uh mediocrity yeah it's the
result of something else
yep
that's what you got yeah all right
well I have something and I that's that
was pretty heavy getting to this point
and I will say what I have is I think
great news okay so let me let me preface
what you're going to say by saying uh
you were in Arizona yes uh given this uh
you were keynoting I was learning about
yeah
um and you were supposed to come back
yesterday and I'm not going to name
names because
um hopefully they redeem themselves but
the airline that you were traveling on
delayed your flight so much that you
missed your next flight and uh you and
Zach were stuck on the mainland last
night and so you just you just got here
you know very shortly before this live
stream and as such we have really not
talked at all about what you did or
about what you're gonna talk about yeah
I'm just like I don't know what he's
gonna do guys all right that was that I
told you I'm gonna deliver some
excellent excellent news I think for all
of us okay um I'm gonna have to get
comfortable then yes yeah I think I
would set Berlin yeah the excellent news
is that I have apparently
finally lost my mind oh boy and the
reason that this is good news I mean it
you know that's not without its down so
I'm not going to share the evidence for
this I will okay but the reason that
this is good news is that I have been on
a very unfortunate winning streak
predicting terrible things in the world
that have then turned out to be true so
the winning streak isn't the unfortunate
part it's the fact that oh yes no it is
the I if I had been wrong about all
these things we'd be in a much better
position but having been right about
them were kind of screwed so
the good news is that I continue to
predict things that are very unfortunate
but it turns out according to Robert
Wright that I have now lost my mind and
uh what's up
um yeah so Robert Wright Robert Wright
author of uh author of the moral animal
and non-zero uh book I have quite liked
um uh let's see if I have it here so it
says you want me to read it sure this is
uh Robert Wright tweeting uh it's
tagging you I've not seen this before so
Brett Weinstein is seriously suggesting
that Democrats have maintained the
vaccine mandate for the military because
their goal is quote degrading military
Readiness in the past I've argued that
some of his crazy sounding theories
aren't completely crazy I'm not arguing
that now
right so Robert Wright when did you
suggest that Democrats maintain the
vaccine mandate for the military because
they go to creating military Badness
this sounds like something you might
have uh proposed as a hypothesis on the
podcast you just released yeah I would
have said that I had proposed it as a
hypothesis apparently according to
Robert Wright I Advanced it as a theory
meaning that it was really the only
viable explanation that does not sound
like it doesn't sound like me so that is
evident if that in fact happened that is
evidence that I have finally lost my
mind
um which is good because it would be
awfully bad if um you know something
that had the ability to degrade our
middle military Readiness was in fact
degrading our military Readiness
um in a form that we cannot Escape right
because the military Readiness is rather
important to the protection of our free
Society so it would be a an alarming
emergency if that were happening
um so in any case
um here is what I am going to suggest so
you want to just you don't want to talk
about what you actually
said no because I think I need to talk
about this with Robert on Dark Horse
okay um so what I'm going to do is and
look this is actually you know you've
heard of win-win situations this is a
win-win-win situation and the reason
it's a win-win-win situation is that I
can't remember it must have been the
second to last time that uh Robert and I
had a discussion I believe this was on
his podcast
his own accounting was that his audience
thought I wiped the floor with him so
this is a chance for him to actually
redeem himself right and if he can
demonstrate that I have in fact lost my
mind we all win because as sad as that
will be for me uh going forward it does
mean that we're in better shape at a
Planet level than I think well I mean I
do I think you're being slightly unfair
to whom
can you put that up again Zach I've
never seen this before but
um does he say that you've lost your
mind he says crazy sounding theories
aren't completely crazy he doesn't say
that you've lost your mind oh he
certainly implied that what he's saying
is and he's correct in the past he has
argued that although certain things that
I say sound crazy maybe they're not he
has argued that and what are you saying
here it's a backhanded
complement basically his point is I'm
not going to argue that anymore
the implication being that I am crazy no
I don't I don't get that from us
actually the implication I get from this
is that this thing that you said which
no you did not propose is a theory uh
but you proposed as a hypothesis
presumably next to other hypotheses
um he thinks that this is completely
crazy he doesn't he's not saying he
thinks you're completely no he says he
thinks it's perfect no no no no no no
first of all if you read it carefully
what he says is he's not going to do
that anymore he's not saying I'm not
going to do that in this case he's
saying I have I am no longer comfortable
with the idea that maybe some of the
things that Brett says that sound crazy
aren't I'm not going to do that I I it
can be read both ways I I don't think so
nonetheless Robert if you would like to
defend yourself on Dark Horse I would
welcome that conversation and my
suggestion is that we have this out and
figure out whether or not I am in fact
seeing
false things or whether or not I am
actually perceiving something important
and real and that in order that you
um feel comfortable with this proposal
we just take the conversation and
broadcast it however it goes no editing
nothing you'd have to worry about you'll
get to say your piece I'll get to say my
piece and the audience can decide for
itself
all right
um
we're there
all right uh I said well you want to do
anything else
um no I mean so we haven't been gone for
very long and uh
there's one point you want at one point
you wanted to talk about uh okay I
okay this is a very clumsy segue which
again Robert is evidence that possibly
supports your hypothesis it clumsy
segment I don't think it's helpful I
don't think I don't think that's what he
said
go back and take a look at it I just did
um
the thing that we are forgetting to
discuss forgetting yeah or choosing that
too nope forgetting okay uh is the
Pamela peresky situation which I believe
we must discuss okay
so Pamela presky uh is a friend of ours
she is a psychologist
um she has she did an awful lot of work
as a
um she was the research assistant
research assistant
in any case she is a very thoughtful
courageous person who has recently had
her account suspended on Twitter
now the reason that her account was
suspended on Twitter I believe
ought to alarm us all
she posted
a uh
series of pictures linked to some
hashtags very obscure hashtags I've
never heard of before
and these basically told Twitter that
Twitter needed to address the fact that
although their terms of service
um forbid
a person to encourage self-harm that
there were in fact communities of people
on Twitter very graphically
uh injuring themselves posting the
evidence and effectively egging each
other on a seemingly obvious violation
of Twitter's terms of service
now of course in an era in which all
institutions are upside down
what Twitter did was instead of
borrowing the accounts that were doing
this or pulling down the hashtags in
which this was being done or eliminating
the posts in which it was being done
they suspended Pamela's account
now that is an amazing inversion of
reality
up until five minutes ago we could all
agree that self-harm was bad especially
young people engaged in self-harm it's a
psychological problem it is a serious
one and the idea that Twitter is going
to play some role in which it allows
people uh to encourage each other into
this behavior is a very dangerous
precedent but to have Twitter respond to
a psychologist pointing out that this is
happening by suspending her account as
if she violated the terms of service is
beyond nuts yeah no it really is uh she
today published a piece on Wesley Yang's
sub stack called year zero
titled Twitter is actively contributed
into the spread of serious self-injury
and suppressing those calling attention
to it I have only I've read a couple
pieces of it and skimmed it but we'll
post that as well in the show notes and
it goes through
um the history even before she showed up
uh looking at this of Twitter doing
nothing about uh pictures of an
encouragement of self-harm all right
it's truly it's truly remarkable and it
is in keeping with other moves afoot now
I will say if you decide to pursue this
uh and look into what she posted what
hashtags
um we're talking about beware you are
heading into a
a graphic and violent realm and
um you should be warned don't don't do
it unless you feel uh you can handle it
and that it you know here's your trigger
warning is basically the point
um
but I also wanted to say something else
about it
um
Pamela is not the only friend of ours
who has found themselves suspended at
Twitter Twitter in particular and
um the
problem
the reason that these people don't come
back is sometimes that they are barred
for life
and sometimes because Twitter insists
that in order to come back what you must
do is delete the tweet and admit that
you violated the terms of service
I believe that many of our friends who
have faced this are actually
you know and it is the result of a
strong aspect a positive aspect of their
character but that they're actually
making a mistake
and what I would say is there is by not
deleting it uh so I don't know which set
of people you're talking about now
so the people who do delete it and come
back on Twitter are the people who don't
delete it and stay people who stay
absent from Twitter and refuse to admit
that they have violated the terms of
service I believe are making an error
and the way I would suggest that we look
at this is
you know let's say that we walked
onto a Battlefield
and we found our
um
troops had draped their equipment in
some kind of camouflage
right
these people are engaged in some morally
compromised Behavior because they're
lying about their equipment right
I don't understand the scene yet well
they're trying to trick people into
thinking they don't have equipment that
they do have that's that's like a lie
okay
so my point is actually
our understanding it is it is a child's
understanding that says it is wrong to
lie if you are fighting for a just cause
using camouflage to hide yourself or
your equipment is a perfectly
justifiable activity even though its
purpose is to mislead right now my point
would be
Twitter
is apparently
fostering the exchange of images in
which those engaged in self-harm
encourage others
to engage in self-harm
that is
a very dangerous behavior these people
are the enemies of those of us who would
protect young people from such
encouragement I think there's maybe an
even bigger or generalizable thing here
which is
um
the
the realization by many that all you
have to do to game a system is say
not me but you
uh you
in this case Twitter comes at Pamela and
says oh you violate our terms of service
she's like I didn't do that
they were already doing it's like no you
did it like no they did it uh the mob
comes to you at Evergreen you're racist
no actually the thing that you're doing
here is the racist thing and you're
destroying the functional system the
people who are gratuitously posting and
encouraging self-harm are destroying the
functional system the you know the
there's some there's something here
around like oh we're gonna get a jump on
uh this person's legitimate claim by
claiming that they're doing the very
thing that we're doing well and I will
go it's worse than that and it's worse
than that in the following way
um the world is actually
measurably safer with Pamela peresky
um minding the space yeah right for sure
this is a very honorable careful
thoroughly educated person who
um compassionate compassionate somebody
who
I'm not even sure I know what her
politics are she's very even-handed
right so this is a Force for good this
is a Force for good that in one instant
gets tossed off of Twitter and can't
come back because it would involve a lie
but my point is that lie is like
fighting the Nazis and using camouflage
to do it it's not a lie well but the lie
comes with I mean I think as you said
you know this better than I do but I
think it's not that
it's not just a lie it's a an ambition
of guilt yeah but
my point when admission of guilt feels
like a lie that has more weight than
than some lies right my point is it's a
bad thing to admit that you committed
some crime that you didn't commit
however Twitter is not a court of law
right it is not in the business or at
least it's not supposed well sure but my
basic point is
um
lying to authoritarians who are involved
in upending the functional aspects of
our system is not a moral compromise
lying to them on any topic and so what I
would Advocate is that for
those who are actually trying to make
the world better
if
those who are trying to make the world
worse whatever their reasons are decide
to Target you right and use your own
Integrity to get you to remove yourself
from the game
don't let them don't let them right if
you're up against Nazis lie to them and
don't let it keep you up at night right
that's what you do now I'm not saying
Twitter or Nazis but what I'm saying is
use the Nazis to figure out whether or
not your principal stands and if lying
to the Nazis is not something you will
do then you're actually a problem if
lying to the Nazis is something you will
do because you understand that it is
important to get the job done then you
can
you can you can continue to play in the
game and my point is look we are worse
off for the friends who have been
eliminated from Twitter
because they won't admit that they
violated the terms of service we are
worse off
certainly we are worse off for having
lost
some of these people
uh
I guess there's a there's a hidden
component
that is precisely hidden we can't know
what the effect is which is that having
said to Twitter yes I violated your
terms of service when you know very well
that you did not you don't know what
kind of file is being kept you don't you
know you don't know how that will be
used against you right so then if it
were me yeah and it surely will be at
some point right I mean I've faced
enough of these close calls I've been
thrown off of Facebook and then restored
when it became obvious that I hadn't
done anything and couldn't have done
anything yeah um but if it were me
if they sent me that thing and said
admit that you violated the terms of
service I would make them minimal
admission and then I would next tweet
would be I just lied to Twitter
is not an official entity it is not the
Arbiter of good it is not a judge of
whether or not you have committed a
crime at best it is an Arbiter of
whether you have violated its terms of
service and obviously it is doing that
in a malicious and incompetent way this
is all true
um I do you know
the game theory will be different for
you than for someone uh with you know
Anne or more than one order for any two
fewer followers and no blue check mark
well right but I guess my point would be
what we have to do and you know we are
doing it right now is pointing out that
this is not a simple matter of hey I'm
not going to admit something I didn't do
Twitter has all the cards all right so
you are playing against somebody who has
all the cards what are you entitled to
do right you are not under oath
right you are admitting on a platform
something and you are free to say here's
why I did that because the elimination
of me from that platform actually makes
the world more dangerous so I'm coming
back and here's how I'm doing it but you
recognize that it's conversations like
this that explains our Wikipedia entries
no I mean go ahead it's a joke oh like
this is exact this is exactly why they
hate us right this is this is exactly
why uh because uh at least you know we
say actually no clothes dude there
Emperor no no clothes and uh they they
don't like that and
we somehow somehow We snuck up on them
and so it's hard to get rid of us now
whereas it will be easier to get rid of
Pamela and some of the other people whom
you are referring to without naming them
um because they don't have the platform
that we do I agree but you know but so
they're they're going at us by
demonetizing us and by Shadow Banning
and by writing slanderous things on
Wikipedia and you know all these other
ways and the fact is uh sorry guys we
still get so many people contacting us
saying thank you keep going I'm in such
a situation and I can't speak up here
but I can share what you do with these
people and this is how we this is how we
build reality and truth and honor back
this is how we do it this is how we do
it but
realize who you're up against what their
actual Authority is and I guess the
point is to the extent that Twitter's
actual Authority only extends as far as
Twitter and what they've done is thrown
you off Twitter lying to Twitter right
the point is you want to be back in the
environment where people are talking I
guess if it's I mean if it's really if
the extent is really just Twitter if the
if if the Twitter universe is entirely
self-contained and they've said you
can't come back until you do Acts
then the costs are completely you know
within Twitter but that but that all of
that rests on the the Assumption which
is that the Twitter universe is
self-contained well I mean it's not
self-contained you know the fascism is
Alive and Well Twitter is you know maybe
even acting under duress from the
executive branch we've certainly seen
the executive branch pressuring uh
platforms to get rid of certain voices
that it finds inconvenient which is an
obvious violation of the first amendment
of course but nonetheless the point is
yes they have a lot of power because
Twitter is a place that matters to the
extent that we rob them of this weapon
we actually make that place better right
we keep the place uh one of diverse
perspectives and I think it is incumbent
on us to do it now I would point out
there are
more Artful ways of navigating this uh
particular conundrum and I would Point
again to John Campbell
not on Twitter but on YouTube Dr John
Campbell yes Dr John Campbell it's
confusing he is a doctor I think he
professionally was a nurse but in any
case he has an excellent YouTube channel
in which he explores
um
the
um various ins and outs of uh research
on covid and its various treatments
he's done an excellent job and he's
extremely careful and his analyzes are
excellent
what he has taken to doing and it this
may not be his most recent video but
it's in the last several of them
was he
points out the evidence that suggests
that there is a major problem with
for example the acknowledgment
the Gaff in which the Pfizer executive
admitted in the European Parliament that
Pfizer did not have evidence that
transmission was blocked by their
so-called vaccine but they were moving
at the speed of science they were moving
at the speed of Science and John
Campbell
lets his emotion show and he becomes
angry in this video and he says I do not
know what those words mean and I have
been studying science since I was 18
years old right this is nonsense but at
the end of his video he says look I'm
not telling you
the facts here because and then he shows
YouTube's
terms of service where it forbids you to
say anything that might imply the
vaccines the so-called vaccines do not
block the transmission of SARS cov2 so
the point is for you YouTube currently
forbids you from saying something that
was admitted by a Pfizer executive in
the European Parliament right that's how
glaring these contradictions are so
anyway my point is look Pamela hit some
tripwire and got tossed off of Twitter
and can only come back if she will admit
to Twitter that she violated their terms
of service which she didn't and was the
entire accusation rests on the fact that
the people Twitter is not doing anything
about are violating Twitter's terms of
service right if all she did is
broadcast said hey why is this going on
on Twitter then the point is well if he
violated the terms of service then all
of the people that she's pointing to did
too and Twitter is not acting against
them so
point being
they don't they don't deserve they don't
deserve this weapon and we are making a
strategic error if we allow that weapon
to have all of this power right it's
like somebody has illegitimately pointed
some rifle at you right that's a
powerful weapon it is not
um
it is not a moral compromise to grab
that rifle and Pull It Forward and
that's what I'm suggesting that we do
right take this weapon from them and
remove its power by simply recognizing
that there is no moral compromise in
lying to Twitter about whether you
violated its terms of service in order
to get back into the discussion that
takes place on Twitter
foreign
okay
um
well maybe that uh
brings us to the end of this
146 live stream it is the 146th
146th Dark Horse live stream it's
somehow it's a tough one isn't it 146th
6th 6th
4646 became deeply uninteresting there
that was my fault but um
all right we are not going to be back
next week but we will be back in 15
minutes so that was maybe set in the
wrong order right we're going to do a q
a shortly here starting with a question
from our wonderful Discord server as we
do every week and then with questions
from you at darkhorsemmissions.com
you are encouraged to read a
hunter-gatherer's guide the 21st century
uh you can find it in more languages
every month at this point including
English which is the one we wrote it in
and join our patreons and uh share
subscribe like share uh if you are if
you are here uh listening or watching
and you made it all the way to the end
presumably there's something of value
for you here so give it a give it a like
and and
help us take that weapon away from uh
from the platforms uh who first for
reasons
that remain a little bit baffling really
don't want reality discussed
in the meantime
be good to the ones you love eat good
food
and get outside and lie to a tyrant
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]